okay hello everyone I'm since this is a
bit of a mixed audience I will start by
introducing the things that I'm going to
talk about i mean it's about quantum
proofs of knowledge but i want to make
sure that everyone knows what I'm
talking about without the word quantum
first it worked earlier
that's that
that's worse my computer seems to have
crashed let's see where they can a tips
real life in some way let's see okay no
its talks again to me so yeah to
introduce the concept and what I'm
talking about let me first say what few
words about what is usually called
postpartum cryptography so in the area
of post quantum cryptography we are
interested in analyzing classical
cryptography so cryptographic protocols
that do actually not in both quantum
mechanics at all so everyone is used
classic computer since classical
messages etc but we asked ourselves are
the result are these protocols still
secure if the attacker has part on
computers so this is a very important
question for all the things we use today
because the things we used today they
have to be classical it's hard to market
something that needs funding of you does
but we wanted them to be secure even my
cousin computers come and when you want
to prove something or construct
something that is secure in a post
quantum setting you will actually need
two different things first you will need
quantum heart problems so for example
many encryption schemes that we use
today are based on assume that factoring
is hard the discrete logarithms that
they are hard and so on and those can't
be used they can be easily broken using
so we need new problems on which we base
the security of the protocols but turns
out that's not the only thing we need
although that's the worry the more
well-known thing one has to think about
the other thing is that we actually need
also new security proofs so a given
construction for example classically
that would use some lettuce assumptions
to prove security
may still be in securing the quantum
setting because the security proofs we
use in the classical setting they often
make transformations on the attacker
that are not meaningful remote quantum
setting so the most common thing and
that which will also be interesting here
is that the state of the adversary's
cottage in some hypothetical a diffusion
and that doesn't make sense for quantum
adversities so it turns out that we need
to revisit all the proofs and it turns
out in some cases it is highly non
obvious how to prove something secure
and one of the most well-known examples
of where it gets hydrogen trivial are
zero knowledge roots and for those who
have never seen as your lifeproof I will
show you what is probably the simplest
zero knowledge proof that is around the
0 is proof for graph isomorphism and
then I will explain what your knowledge
means so for a moment just consider this
picture we have approval and verify and
approval so there are two graphs g and h
and the prover wants to convince the
verifier that these two graphs are
isomorphic and we can use the following
simple protocol is um the provo takes
one of the graphs say graph G and
permute sit so applies are a random
isomorphism to this graph and send it
the permuted graph to the verify this
permitted graph was not revealed I
bought this drop because it's truffled
where we will see more formally why it
doesn't reveal it then the verifier
picks one of these two graphs so it
picks in that g 0 h and tends to the
very approval which he has picked and
now the crucial step is that the proof
of Nina has to send an isomorphism
between G J&G so between the purview to
G and the original going to j the
original G all between J and H depending
on with the verifier wanted and now you
can convince yourself that this is
if this if the proof I can do this it is
kind of a proof because if G and H are
not isomorphic it means that no matter
what to prove odd us at least one of
these two graphs will be not isomorphic
to Jay because they can't be both as
morphine and therefore is probably one
half the prover will not be able to
answer this question not yet so this
even if the statement is wrong the
prover can cheat with probably one half
but there we can use standard
amplification techniques like sequential
repetition to get the success
probability other cheating probability
down exponentially so that's not a
problem so that's what that's the kind
of proofs who have a look at and now let
me say something about the zero
knowledge property so how does your
knowledge means that the verifier
doesn't learn anything and how can we
convince ourselves that this protocol
does it need not reveal anything about
the attack well what we do is we
construct a hypothetical machine the
simulator which is able to simulate
exactly the same messages as the
verifier saw but without interacting
with the poopit so if we go back to this
protocol what you essentially have to do
I mean I'm simplifying here but
essentially you pick a random graph you
pick either gia or gah shuffle it
randomly then you get a graph J which
has the same distribution as this one
and where you know the isomorphism from
this chopard graph is up to G or H and
then you make up the fact that you asked
for that particular one and then you
have all the messages from the right
distribution so I mean ok we could prove
this formula but reward because that's
not the topic here but the point is you
can construct the machine that simulates
everything does the verifier sees
without interacting with approval and
that means that the verified hasn't done
anything because if the only thing the
verifier sees a message is he could have
made up himself then these messages were
clearly not telling them
about the secrets of the provo like the
isomorphism between G&H and that that's
the reason why this protocol is your
knowledge and actually even the terms
your knowledge is defined in terms of
having such a simulator um there's one
subtlety here yeah yes before we talk
about the fact is that J in will be well
in the oddest case J is isomorphic to
both of them and we can just always show
it I smoke weed the one or the other but
in the dis on this case when G and H are
not isomorphic then J cannot be
isomorphic to both so could we here
instead of providing an isomorphism
between Jay and one of them why are we
not asking for a nice more person just
between Jeannie because then we won't be
able to prove the zero knowledge
property because then we would get
something we yep so there are protocols
for this because it's in NP then there's
always a very simple no interactive
protocol but we want to get Maggie to
prove and to be zero knowledge at the
same time and that's probably the simple
photo vote for that okay but there let
me now say a bit more detail how the
simulator works in such a setting and
then I will be a bit more general and
talk about so called Sigma protocols we
have three messages commitment challenge
and response um and in many cases the
simulator will look more or less like
this he guesses first what the challenge
will be I mean he has a probability of
one half of guessing correctly I don't
think so
okay so he has probably of one half of
guessing the right challenge so he just
guesses what the verify will ask here
and then he sends his first message
called the commitment which is the graph
Jade gets the challenge which is the
selection which one to open and then he
can respond if he used the right
challenge because getting their
challenge means he knows beforehand to
which of the two graphs you would have
to open however it may be that he gets
wrong and then he just resets the
verifier into the original state and
tries again and he does this in a loop
until he gets the challenge correctly
and gets out of you so that's how
simulators what simulators look like
very often and in particular they look
like this in the graph isomorphism
protocol however in the quantum case
this does not work why because rewinding
like going back to an earlier state
implies copying of a quantum state
because they verify here has some stage
in some internal state and it may be
quantum and running it and then going
back to the state means I need to make a
copy of that steak run and then restore
this this copy and this can't be done
because it's yeah because of the mall
cloning theory so because of this it was
at first completely non-obvious whether
these protocols are actually secured the
quantum setting at all fortunately I'm
around I think 2006 john bockris showed
that a large class of protocols
including the kind of protocols have
just shown to you actually are quantum
zero knowledge because we can do a
variant of the rewinding so we cannot
copy the state of the adversary and
because of what we have to do instead is
when we want to go back in time we have
to uncomplete what we did so imagine you
have this simulator sim that is like
able to do one in one try and that needs
to go back if your friends so what we do
is we run this one try simulator that
tries to do a simulation and then we
measure whether
simulator succeeded or set I fade and if
it says I failed we need to restore an
earlier state and this cannot be done by
copying it instead we just apply the
inverse of the simulator if the
simulator is unitary transformation
which you can always ensure it means we
can go back in time this is not trivial
because we have this measurement in
between so they don't cancel out and
this is where the launcher ability of
this approach comes from so you need to
do some additional stuff and then go
back and then you can add this loop
until your success and magically turns
to work out and in the mathematics
involved you can see that what's
happening is kind of similar to
amplitude amplification yes yes because
it's classical that was in question
right so you're saying that basically
copy some states this is what he does
classic how he does it classically so
but if I wasn't cranky this is the
various fires the verifier should yep
but he also can prepare the state sighs
so he has no problem no well then we
would get memory into the details of the
definitions but we assume that there is
some initial state coming from the
outside like an an officer in that
represents the auxiliary information
that the verify may have over the world
and that is also given to the simulator
so similar does not get several copies
if you don't do that you could check can
change the definition and not do that
then it might be easy to do a simulation
or not sure but then you get into
trouble when you want to use it as a sub
protocol because if you have some
earlier protocol run this is not
captured and you may have insecurities
so you have to do this in order for
things to work out smoothly and if you
do it you run into these problems and
things don't
so okay so this is um how you can prove
the security of quantum zero knowledge
for reports so classical protocols but
you want them to be secure quantumly
however there are some limitations of
this approach that I would like to
mention here because they come up later
so it works fine for the example I
showed but the if we take it as a
general technique there are two
limitations we have to be a well the
first limitation is when we rewind the
simulator so when the similarity goes
back to an earlier state in by doing
this I'm computer mutation then he
forgets everything he has ever lived
because we apply the inverse anything
will be uncompleted can't be that the
simulator finds out some interesting
number and then after rewinding still
knows that number this is why I
sometimes say that worthless rewinding
is an oblivious rewinding we can say we
want to try again but if we do we have
even forgotten that this already the
second try and the similar it doesn't
remember anything and certain there is a
technical condition that the success
probability needs to be independent of
the initial state so the probability
that one iteration of the simulator
succeeds must be independent of the
initial state this is the case in the
example we had because the profit is
always one half that you guess the
challenge right but you can come up with
situations where you have a simulator
which can be sometimes a bit more
successful than probably one half and
then suddenly we can't apply motorist
rewinding theorem and the intuition a my
interpretation is that the success
whether it succeeds should carino
information or the initial state because
if it does carry information then
measuring this would pull out
information of the initial state and
therefore disturb it but that's just my
intuition of it and yeah i forgot to
mention in this talk i will have these
nice open problems take us all the time
when there is something where i think
that i personally would find
quite interesting if someone me or you
would solve it so like whether we can
generalize this to cases where where the
success provision changes strongly
depending on the state I don't know
anything and later we'll see you we're
depending on the time a place where it
would be useful to have something like
that so that's the solve the question of
quantum geologic well the reminding
techniques covers many important derange
proofs but it turns out it's not as
powerful as classical rewinding so one
example that I like to mention in this
case is the proof for graph isomorphism
i'm not going to show you this proof but
if you know it it's one way a lot of
it's kind of a if you solve that if you
show that that one is quantum secure you
will probably soften out a number of the
open problem in the rest of these talks
on the way so that's an interesting one
so it doesn't cover all zeros proofs and
it also does not call carbon so called
proof of knowledge so let me explain to
you what proofs of knowledge are so
imagine we want to let me give a use
case you have a digital passport which
has a certificate on on all your
personal data on it like a signature on
something like Ellis is born on this or
that date and now I want to log in
somewhere I want just to prove to the
web service that I am at least 18 if
it's a cat shouldn't be proving it's at
least three or something
in these yeah that's a good point i
should change this life i will remember
that for the next up ok so but this is
something really a diet so can't even
catch have to be a 18 so how does we
can't do that the cat Navy would say oh
we use a thorough knowledge proof we
show there is a signature on some date
that is be earlier than whatever was 18
years ago and here's all this work might
be totally insecure why because the
mathematical statement there exists the
signature on a message of a certain form
is always true because the signatures
always exists I mean maybe we can't say
something like someone has issued this
signature we can just say this number
exists yeah and our success team if we
don't know it so as zero knowledge proof
will be not useful for this because the
property of being approved with only
guarantee that the signature exists not
let the prove our knows it so therefore
we need something stronger we need a way
that the prover can not only prove that
a signature exists but he should be all
she should be able to prove that she
knows the signature or in general if you
have some NP problem you want to prove
that you know witness um let me quickly
go to the graph isomorphism again just
to illustrate that this is not that is a
reasonable thing to hope for in this
setting for example it's hard to come up
with a way to to do this interaction if
I don't know an isomorphism 4G between
G&H because I need to be able to go from
j both 2g and to h and this i can only
do if i have the isomorphous and this is
something we were formalized in that
case it is a group of knowledge this one
is a proof of knowledge yet and well
it's a classical proof of knowledge it's
open but that's a quantum proof of
knowledge actually but very similar
protocols are also provably quantum
proof of knowledge
or as I if the graphs are guaranteed to
be too rigid graphs if both if the
graphs G and H are guaranteed to have
none to have trivial autumn efficient
group then this is a quantum proof of
knowledge ok this is a lot of clicking
ok so the question is how do we prove
such a thing I mean I've been hand
waving and saying the Hoover if he
succeeds he should know the witness but
what does you knowing if me so what we
want is to capture this intrusion if the
probe is successful then the proven owes
a witness I know we want to replace this
by something more formal let's first try
the prover could output the witness yeah
we can't say something like the witness
is in the like a substring of his memory
because it might be obfuscated in some
way but what knowing intuitively means
is if I know something it means that if
you would ask me I would be able to tell
you so this comes already closer to what
we want but it's a bit I mean it doesn't
really mean anything because the prover
is a concrete algorithm yeah and the
Eiger isn't can't do anything else and
what is programmed to do yeah it's like
asking yeah I have equipped quicksort
algorithm and then I ask can this also
factorize yeah this is not a meaningful
question now the quick tail I cannot
factorize perps the computer can
factorize or the deck I have to run the
quicksort is sufficient to factorize or
something like this but it doesn't make
sense to ask whether the quick tour I
will affect us oh it does make sense in
the answer is no so we need to change
this likely and the definition that
choreographers came up with is the
following the we were good compute
witness is reformulated by saying
there's some other machine that given
the prover state could compute the
witness so there is a machine or
algorithm called an extractor that given
the prover state cannot put the witness
so if I can come up with some machine
that give my state cannot put a certain
thing then I say I knew this thing
I'm yeah let's see yeah first I give you
the definition for those who are
interested slightly more formally so
it's quantifiers and so on so they are
variants of this with reorder and
quantifiers also but let's use this one
so more formally this is there is a
polynomial time extractor e so that for
any malicious prove our p star that
tries to cheat has we have the following
if the malicious prove ah makes the
verifier except with some probability
alpha which is not very small then we
want that the extractor with when
running the proverb p star as a black
box so they think of it as give them as
an Oracle that this extract ER can now
output the witness of the statement that
is proven with some other not too small
probability and then we have some
formula like how this probability of the
prover succeeding relates to the
probability of the vector succeeding but
let's not worry about that right now so
this is just an abstract definition that
models what we would like but do we get
that well let's look at the the I
extractor gets everything that the that
the malicious prove our would have empty
gets the malicious proven but this one
and this means that if the extractor
outputs a witness it means the prover
could also have output that witness
because he has exactly the same
information to start with they may be
variants where they exerted a slightly
more stuff but that's not the setting we
have you um okay so how do we construct
extractors think again of a product of a
sigma protocol so a protocol of the sky
like this graph isomorphism protocol
wherever commitment a challenge and
response and we try not to construct an
extractor as follows the provo sends a
commitment or some the graph J then we
answer with a random challenge as the
verifier would and then we get his
response
so for example in the graph isomorphism
protocol we would now have gotten very
isomorphism between this commitment J
and one of the two graphs and then once
we have that we go back in time so we
rewind to this state here and give the
other challenge and get a response and
now we have an isomorphism to the other
of the two graphs so we have this
situation from Jay Bevin I so f into g +
2 H so we can easily compute an
isomorphism between G&H and this is a
way how give them the proof as a black
box we can extract a witness and this
property so what we used here is the
property of this interaction that if you
have one commitment so we have two
executions that have the same commitment
but different challenges and both are
correct like accepting then you can
efficiently compute the witness from
that and this is called special
conference two different responses allow
us to compute the witness and graph
isomorphism has this we have just seen
it like two responses give us the two as
mph isn't and there are lot of other
protocols of that kind that have this
property and then you can generally
state to protocol if a protocol has
special soundness then is the proof of
luggage in the classical setting yes in
the particular graph isomorphism example
there was a graph that J that is
isomorphic to well to both actually
because they are isomorphic yeah so only
the dishonest case there's difference in
the case where the prover is cheating
then it might be not isomorphic but for
the two one of them bottom wire no no
this it's the the prover since that
commitment let's leave the task and I
mean in the proof of knowledge we are
now only considering like malicious
prove us anyway because we want to show
that they have to know something is
these proofs of knowledge we're now
implicitly assuming that the prover is
computationally bounded other than they
NP witness that you may have somehow
know there are different variants on
that they are so-called arguments of
knowledge there you make this assumption
but improve of knowledge you do not make
that assumption however it is a bit it
may be a bit confusing because an
unbounded proven you could say an
improver always knows the witness
because it's determined by the graphs
but this guarantees is that no matter
how unbounded to prove is it will not be
easier for him to do the proof than to
actually compute the witness because the
extractor is bounded well that's what I
was wondering because if the extractor
is bounded the proofer might know the
witness but he could encode it in
something that takes exponential time to
decode exactly but the thing is we can
always pull it out of the provo using
this rewinding so no matter what this
guy does if we ask him for example for
the two graphs and you produce the true
drafts we know the witness and our the
overhead so essentially it says the
overhead for getting the witness
compared to just doing the proof is
small and this will with your special
sounds you can show that this always
works essentially the extraction
probability will be quadratic up to
stuff in the in the verification
probability in the classical setting so
when you have access to the proofer for
this particular extractor you also need
like a an Oracle that allows you to
rewind you can just imagine an orgo that
says well hey you've already asked me oh
yeah I mean in the precise definitions
you could either say it's like we know
the initial randomness and we have a
deterministic we make it like say old r
enemas chosen at the beginning and then
you can just also rerun the whole thing
to the same point that's solid sometimes
done that doesn't regenerate the quantum
setting the way because we can't fix the
randomness or you could have something
Raven quick to snap shots that would be
in the classical setting be equivalent
and the quantum setting we will assume
that you have the inverse of the unitary
operation that encodes the proven
okay what about quantum proofs of
knowledge no in the quantum case we
again can't do it that way because we
know rewinding is not easy we had this
thing that we want to go after getting
the first response below to go back and
get the second one but since John has a
reminder techniques we could ask can we
just apply it here no because as I
mentioned there's this oblivious
property if we rewind as well that was
about simulators but technique is
generally about were running some
machine so if the extractor tries to go
back to an earlier state so the
extractor tries to go back here he could
try to apply John's technique but since
it's oblivious he will be here and he
will have forgotten the response because
he's required to UM compute the response
so there's nothing gained because at the
end he will just remember one execution
so we can't use the existing technique
and this is how we're my work starts I
proof that there is an alternative
strategy how in certain cases not in all
cases but all in certain cases sorry we
just stop it well I have 15 minutes to
click restart later in a fortunate next
time it comes I can actually leave it on
because I think they know it will reboot
when they run out of time or something
okay so so the the extra like the
classical extractor is doesn't work
because it uses copying and we can't
even express it in the quantum setting
but we can try to do the next best thing
we can just assume that well there are a
lot of issues but whenever I want to go
back I just apply the inverse of
whatever I can apply the inverse off and
the things that I don't have an inverse
of like the measurements I just leave
them I saw it's just to agree a try
where that works yes
I know but in the classical setting it
is not a copying off an unknown in an
unknown basis so if the approver would
be a classical algorithm then even in a
quantum setting you could remind him
because you could measure an anon basis
estate but in the general setting the
prover is malicious and you might do he
might start with a quantum state in some
basis and we don't know in which one and
then the task at least if we try to make
a direct translation from from the
description of the classical procedure
for extracting into the quantum
procedure there would be like the step
and now please clone and of course there
could be variants of what cloning mean
you could try imperfect cloning and so
on but then you have to find out what
happens and all I'm saying is there's no
direct translation because there's a an
arm on stayin home no I need it for only
for this honest proof of sexually yeah
for this honest prove us because what I
want to prove is that if I go back to
this I want to prove that if this proved
up sends this to the verifier then
disproven also a signature well I'm not
so concerned with prove us were honest
because I trust them to know the
signature anyway I'm more concerned with
some proven who is under 3 and wants to
claim I know a signature that I my team
and this should not be possible so we
will apply to that prove are an
extractor get a witness get a get the
actual signature and have a
contradiction so this is why we apply it
always to malicious purpose of course we
can also apply to the oddest proven but
that will be boring you should
okay so here's what i call the canonical
extractor I'm just doing everything I I
need and hope it will work and then I
analyze later with a plus so what is the
natural thing to do if I have a proven a
malicious proved up and I want to
extract well first I run the approval
which is unitary transformation to do
the first part of its computation where
its outputs a commitment then I measure
that commitment um then I run to prove
our code again another unitary
transformation and then I measure look I
make a run the unitary transformation
that represent the computation that the
prover does if I give him some challenge
one and then I can measure the response
so this thing is just the normal
execution of the protocol we run the
proof I get the commitment give us
challenge get a response but now what we
wanted if you look at this picture so we
have done this and then we want to go
back to the point before we gave the
challenge so we just uncompleted we
apply what we can't undo this
measurement why we could but then we
will forget them and no response so we
leave that but we undo what to prove
added here so we apply the inverse of
what the prover does giving challenge
one and then we assume that we are kind
of in this state and then we apply what
the proof over to a challenge to and
measure the response and that way we get
a 2 interactions starting with the same
commitment and with different challenges
and now we can analyze whether this
actually works so does this give us
whatever because what we need is we need
to execution from the same commitment
that we have but both executions should
be execution that I accepted by the
verifier I mean we can anyway makeup
triples of values but we need like in
the graph isomorphism example we would
need that in both executions hear the
response is actually a correct item
office and from these two we could
construct the witness so we need to make
sure that this process here it gives us
two executions assuming that one
in a normal execution the prover has
some high success probability okay does
this work well it's tricky because we
have at this point what we were hoping
that this unit area is this unitary they
are inverse of each other just cancel
each other out but that's not the case
because we have a measurement in between
and unitary measurement inverse of the
unitary that you don't have any
simplification rule for that unless the
unitary commutes with the regiment but
it does not in generally here so if we
have this measurement here reminding
face and it's relatively easy to
construct particular provers meniscal
this extractor will fail so you could
just include into this response some
outcome of some measurement and then
you're in totally different sage and it
does go back so it seems that this
extract it does not work but let's make
it a thought experiment let's assume
that this response atoms has a length of
only one bit this may be may seem
useless because there are no protocols
where the response is only one [ __ ]
because if there were you could just
guess the response easily inside city
improving quite often so there are no
protocols with this property but let's
assume you have this sorry response is
now only one bit so this means that at
this point here we make a measurement of
only one bit and the less information we
put out of a quantum state the nest we
disturb it at least that's what we
intuitively expect for example if you
have a measurement where the old answers
already determined that's a zero bit
measurement then you just don't disturb
the state at all you have a 1-bit
measurement and if you do the math here
so the mouth of this is kind of the main
technical thing you find out yep it does
work so this disturbance is moderate
enough so that the whole thing works out
with somewhat different bonds than in
the classical case
but it does work yes how is it is cy
measuring me one bit mixing me moderate
this up and say that one bit could have
been used to control is there a wide
operation so he racing yeah it's
essentially some playing around with
linear linear algebra I mean don't have
a clear intuition it's just the less
information you pull out the less you
disturb and the thing is but more likely
this this bit is to be the one I mean if
if this has even less entropy than one
bit it gets even less disturbance and
the thing is a proven that is often
successful will have even less than one
bit because if there are two right
answers but only one of them if they're
two answers only one of them is a
correct one and we have to prove my
lettuce for example correct in
ninety-nine percent of the cases then
you have even less the stones so you
need to do the math and see how big does
does the the buyers have to be here in
this outcome so that the disturbance
will be small and then you need to see
that the different cases are like
they're different challenges and you
need to see that the sums behave nicely
and so on I don't have an intuition for
that it can show your mouth but come to
anything else I don't I essentially have
a proof that this whole thing works so
this disturbance thing is the intrusion
and formally it's just I have a relation
between the probability that it works
until here to get a correct response and
the probability it goes until you that's
all that's what I have to know these sub
things are just intuitive what yeah but
the thing is we are in the thought
experiment we haven't solved anything we
don't have one bit responses but what we
can do is to make the response to be
effectively one bit how can we do that
the thing is assume our sigma protocol
has an additional property assume that
for any chair so for any commitment any
challenge so there we are verify
supposed the proof is supposed to send
some response and there may be many
responses that would be accepting
but assume we have managed to construct
a protocol where there's exactly one at
most one valid response for any start of
the entire tree so once commitment and
challenge have been sent there's at most
one response that does not mean that we
sent only one bit and it can be that
this response is hard to compute but it
has to be determined and since these
mathematics about measurements don't
worry about whether it's easy to compute
what we sent but only about the
information content having a response
that is uniquely determined in case it's
valid is essentially equivalent to
having just one ascending one just one
big because essentially what we sent is
the information whether we are sending
the right quick response or some other
response so this is what I call strict
soundness for any challenge there's at
most one response and by using the same
markers in the thought experiment we can
see if we have this additionally this
property of strict soundness then this
canonical extractor works but there's
this additional property of strict
soundness and it's an open problem or
whether this is actually necessary but
before you jump on to that one we have
almost solved it relative to some Oracle
so don't duplicate work there but if you
have some answer like without Oracle's
that were we still very interesting or
if we have a bug in the proof then it
was also the interesting okay so here's
the formal statement of what we actually
get so assuming the expression and
strict saltness then we know that the
problem here if extracting is at most
the probability of verifying minus one
over a square root of the number of
challenges to the power of three this is
a bit different from what we get in the
classical setting in the classical
setting the exponent here is 2 and this
square root is not there so the bound is
worse but this does not really change
anything qualitatively it essentially
just would mean that if you want to
amplify this to something
with good quality you need around twice
as many rods which is so yeah it's minor
oh my nothing but whether you can
improve this bount is another open
problem oh I don't know whether it's
necessarily I mean you get this these
westbound because you have in addition
to what happens in the quantum setting
at in the quad classical setting you
have this disturbance by measuring the
response and this disturbance gives you
one factor more of this thing
essentially are you need to put the
wrong then then this would mean that if
the verifier is has a success problem if
the prover has a bird verify correctly
probability that is noticeably bigger
than one over square root of two then
this means that there is a witness in
his head because then you could extract
that witness with noticeable probation
so as long as the right hand side is
positive yeah well weekly like I wanted
to be noticeable like 1 over polynomial
so this cube we didn't really care yep
the way we might can specific
applications but in the classical
setting you can actually repeat the
extractor to get this down but we can't
do that here so it may be that their
situation where the cube is worse than
the square but the square could also be
worse than to the one square root you'd
expect this should not be there or you
can I just say that my analyst I I would
expect that the canonical extractor
probably doesn't have it there has it
they're necessarily but I don't have a
proof of that we produce graph
isomorphism e.g you said this doesn't
apply because it doesn't have strict
sounds you could have to graph you can
have several isomorphisms so that you
would need that the ultima facin group
of both graphs are trivial then it will
have strict orders and then you will get
all these kinds of property
just one more here's what they say you
could modify this Wi-Fi services in
protocol so that it has um well I can
with computational assumptions I don't
have an unconditional variant of the
graph isomorphism protocol that is
secure okay a second thing which is open
here is commutation and security so if
these two properties hold only
computationally does the whole thing
work out or not and I I think it does me
but that is the direction related to
this one I think what techniques here
also work here but that's even less
written up and then what here so just
saying probably there's some big trouble
ahead if you go if you try to make the
whole thing work if these things only
hold against putting on the time
adversary's yeah the properties as
mentioned before the graph isomorphism
proof does not have strict saltness in
general and it's an open problem whether
you can prove the graph as verson
Protocol secure or whether you can vary
it in a way that doesn't use commutation
assumptions to let it become secure an
example of a proof that has strict
softness is the proof a well no proof
for proving that you know a discrete
logarithm but that's boring in the
quantum setting because the extractor
can just compute the district over it
and I actually don't know any natural
protocols that have a strict saltless
but I mean there are so many there there
might be some I just don't know which
one have perhaps yeah I don't know I
mean I'm just saying I'm not aware but I
would have to look at each protocol but
I this it has it or not I'm not saying
down this is this is not open problem
like finding others this is just my lack
of overview what of all the zeros proves
that all there but if we want to get
their knowledge for all languages in NP
have Sigma protocols for languages NP
but another way of any that has on its
own strict soundness so what we can do
in this case at least four protocols a
number of challenges polynomially
bounded and we can always achieve that
you can always cut down the number of
challenges then you can just in the
first message the commitment same
edition your commitment to all the
answers I would give for all the
different challenges and if this
commitment itself has the property that
the opening information is uniquely
determined then what I get has again
strict something so if I'm probably
there constrict binding that means that
i can open the commitment only in one
way so not only the thing inside but
even the information i make to prove
that i opened it correctly if that's
both unique then everything works out I
keep strict soundness I put ad
computational assumptions on the 0h part
but we're 40 h 4 11 p we need it anyway
and we get this by plugging these ideas
and existing proof systems for
hamiltonian cycles and commitment from
injector for neural functions together
we get assuming injective 12 one-way
functions Quantum's emerge proof of
knowledge exist for all languages
infinity there's a caveat we don't
currently as far as i know have
injective owner functions but there are
quantum secure um so that should be
easily obtainable that I mean if you
just pick any kind of scrambling
operation that maps and bits to say
three and bits yeah I mean you can
probably just yeah do something which is
blowing up let's say I don't I don't
know any candidates where someone has
actually proven that they injected if
you use just some scrambling it might
not be easy to prove that they're really
injective with all my exponential
probability yeah yeah so I guess like
practically I would just as you expect
as except as a candidate something like
a hash function worthy I don't use the
full input domain or something yeah but
we don't have any kind of nice
candidates we've just why it's coming as
I know yes so it would be interesting to
have some more insights into this one I
how much time do I have left no it's
good um so now i have show it told you
everything that i wrote down in the
paper about quantum proofs of knowledge
but since then i stumbled upon the
number of things then or not as good as
one would like so we're things that are
easy in the classical case are not easy
in the quantum case because let's let's
try to actually use quantum extractor to
prove something on sugar and the first
time I ran into trouble using a quantum
proof of knowledge was when I proved
something which I have here cut down to
a minimum example so assume we have
approver who is malicious and who has
access to a sign up so someone signs to
disprove are arbitrary messages except
that the message 0 is never signed so
that's refused this is some kind of
simplified setting about this improving
my age thing where I should want to
prove that I'm so he or she wants to
prove that she has a signature on well
she gets a signature on anything except
zero for whatever reason and now the
proven tries is supposed to produce and
prove that she knows a signature on zero
yeah so she has access to someone who
signs anything except zero and she tries
to prove that she knows the signature of
zero intuitively expect that it
shouldn't be possible for malicious
proved up to succeed in this proof
because she knows any signature except
the signature on zero so it should be
that in this game the probability that
the verify accepts is negligible and how
do we prove that well let me prove it in
the classical setting first because
there is relatively easy so assume you
have a proven that succeeds in this
interaction with non-negligible
probability and then we take the
extractor we know that there is an
extractor where if I apply it to the
prover
I get something that outputs a witness
so if i apply to the prove up well i
can't apply to the prove on its own
because from the point of view of the
verifier these two machines together are
the proven yeah that's what the better
fire interacts with its the assignment
approval in one machine so I again give
to the extractor proven and China as a
black box and then using this rewinding
stuff we extract the managers to get
witness so witness is the signature on 0
so by using the proof large property we
have constructed an extractor which
outputs a signature on 0 but this X
tractor does not have direct access to
the signing key he has only access to
this Oracle here internally that does
not sign the number zero and from the
security of signatures it follows that
you cannot get a signature of 0 if you
have only access to a signing Oracle
that signs everything but 0 it's called
suspension unfortunately so we have now
an extract Annette find Z a signature 0
giving all given only signatures are
nonzero and that's a contradiction so
this original poova cannot exist what
happens in the quantum setting let's try
the same thing there the extractor has
access to the prover so this thing but
he also uses the inverse of the program
so the unitary transformation that is
like the inverse so now we have an
extractor that uses essentially where we
can visit boring but he uses the signing
Oracle and use the inverse of the
signing Oracle and he finds a signature
well so what we have is an extractor
that finds a signature give them only
someone who signs 10 messages and the
inverse of someone who signs only
nonzero messages and that gives a
contradiction but none of that leaves no
contradiction so the proof fates in this
case at the first glance you may say
well but the inverse of assigning Oracle
is also signing Oracle because signing
Oracle is stateless and the status
oracle ists you can build it by saying
like input x and y i make x i make it
into x
White's or signature necks and if I add
this self inverse so any sailors Oracle
is actually self inverse or can we made
self inverse and therefore the program
wouldn't happen but actually if you try
to do this in detail you will notice a
signing Oracle is not stateless because
well it may seem stateless but the
security finition about which talks
about these talks of assessable it talks
about messages that you have not it
cited it talks about the list of
messages you have signed so the signing
Oracle actually if you make everything
formal has a state namely the list of
messages that it signs and the inverse
will like unsigned messages and then you
don't know anything anymore so actually
hard to prove things like that is
surprisingly open but with other things
like I prove something about like this
encryption contains a certain number so
in some settings that work smoothly in
other settings it doesn't so that's a
bit surprising but similar things can
also a classically I mean if this would
be some interactive Oracle then the
whole thing would run into similar
problems classically except that there
are more problems quantity another thing
where we have problems is if we use as
your knowledge proof as a sub protocol
in some bigger protocol we have
sometimes this situation so for example
if you construct a secure multi-party
computation we may start with a classic
over the passively secure protocol and
in every step we prove the message I'm
sending now is the right message and for
this user knowledge protocol so this
makes actually a protocol that was
secure against adversary's that
oppressive that only listen to the
messages into one where even a cheating
adversity that doesn't tries to send
wrong messages cannot cheat because he
always needs to say prove that he sends
the right message without revealing
anything sociology so and if you go
through the proof of such constructions
you have like some stuff happens then
you have the zero knowledge proof and
then some more stuff happens and then at
some point in the proof you want to
apply the extractor so you will then
have stuff happens
the extractor runs more stuff happens
and then this side and this side they
should be indistinguishable what happens
if you plug in an extractor like the one
we have the ones we have seen so far
well this extractor has then some
non-negligible probability of socks some
noticeable probability of succeeding but
ultimate fails so this thing will not be
indistinguishable from this thing
because this fails of them and this
doesn't classically no problem if they
extract the phase we try again we
amplify the success probability but just
restarting the extract a lot of times in
the quantum setting how can we do that
well it seems we have the tool for that
because here we want oblivious rewinding
we have an extract of that fade so we
want to let it try again so we it seems
you can use mattress technique but no
this is oblivious but we have the second
limitation that the success should be
independent of the initial state and
here we have an extract if you look at
this extractor here we have a minimal
like we can show for example it always
at least probability one quarter of
succeeding but there could be some stay
initial states whereas more success yeah
there we are don't have an upper bound
success can go up and down between
something and at one and therefore we at
least cannot apply the theorem for
motors paper it might be that the the
vibration their works here but we don't
know it so how you make an extractor
like output the witness in on the run
time with a higher probability is an
open problem it should appear here and
this applies for example to the g LW
compiler that I just mentioned that make
specific secures active passive
protocols actively secure but also in
the graph mount isomorphism proof that i
mentioned already same problem occurs
because they use a
an extractor in the proof of the zero
knowledge property I mean this sounds
weird but if you look at the protocol it
makes sense so this is another case
where classically it works fine but
quantumly we don't know anything yet so
let me conclude I mean them if more open
problems when you come to things in the
random Oracle model but I don't have
another hour so I won't say that so let
me conclude what I've shown you is that
zero knowledge and proofs of knowledge
are objects that bring us a lot of new
challenges in the quantum setting and in
some basic situations we have solved
these things but there are many unsolved
issues and one kind of challenge that I
issue is like proof proud momma is
morphism secure because I think that on
the way you will find out about a lot of
things about then I useful for other
protocols and it's important to study
these things because these problems are
not restricted to zero knowledge and
proofs of knowledge all the times in
crypto these things appear again the
same problem so in cryptography zero
knowledge and proofs of knowledge are
kind of the drosophila of cryptography
all the a lot of the challenging things
that had monographie can be investigated
in the simplest setting when you look at
zero knowledge and a proof of knowledge
and you get the really hard settings
when you start doing multi-party
computation or or other Wilder things so
we should trust kind of understand them
on the basic level and then we can go to
the advanced problem okay that's it and
I thank for your attention
I don't know anything so it's an
interesting question can you do what
they're two interesting things one is
you have a classical fact you want to
prove yes a language but you want to use
quantum interaction interesting question
whether you can do more or not but I
haven't worked on that side I don't
really know and the other question is
you have actually a quantum stake so
your language is quantum you want to
prove this one of state has a certain
property I also don't know well actually
you get things like that to some extent
as it wears there are some results I
forgot like the author's put down by now
results on multi-party computation on
quantum states and if you use these
protocols actually they specialize down
to something that should be
computational like that should have
these things in a computational setting
but you get protocol splits had much
higher on complexity and only
computation security and possibly more
assumptions so it doesn't really it it's
like much bigger protocols than you
would might need but there are some
solutions that would give you some
results in that direction
you discuss this problem with using the
proof of knowledge in front of a larger
critical quick when you could get a
signature of zero from signatures
announcer things I understand the
problem correctly is that because you're
only allowed to query your signature
Oracle classically you weren't belonging
very important um no but I kind of if
you had a signature or village to secure
when queried in quantum superposition
you not deal with just I'm I bet the
problems that you still have this
message log of what are fresh messages
you because this is the security of
signature says you cannot produce a
signature that you have improved but so
you get that then you get already in a
lot of definitional issues and similarly
yeah the signature scheme this stateless
but and I think that well that
particular escaped on example that are
shorter way it's always nonzero then
it's I think then it work would actually
work out even without acquiring unit
superposition but if you have something
like you want to guarantee that the
approver does not prove that he knows
any make a signature that he hasn't
cleared then you will need a signal
Oracle that signs everything but you
will need my person of the Oracle but
someone in the definition of what we do
will make a list of messages that
required and you may not call it part of
the Oracle but you will see that this
thing will be neat will be wrong we
wrong re want to and then yeah I'm not
it may be that the work that has been
done on signatures where you can Korean
superposition and have security it can
be that this gives us something here but
it's not obvious so I don't see that it
would but i also don't see that it
wouldn't I don't even see that a normal
signature scheme wouldn't be wouldn't
work here I mean I only wasn't able to
prove it
13 minutes left here well before the
break I just wanted to make a quick
announcement so the since this came up
this morning so on on the schedule for
friday afternoon there's uh something
that's called drum session or discuss
certain session or wrap-up session so i
think we have like an hour and a half
scheduled for this so i just want to
invite all of you to think of anything
you want to bring up so this could be uh
you know we thought you want to mention
or a question that you want to ask the
audience before everyone disappears you
have all these experts available for you
or just you know some discussion point
you want to break up so as long as it
fits in under five minutes it's it's
good so just to keep it sort of
organized with us that you are getting
tortured by the turret or John or myself
or send me an email just to say you know
I'd like to say something about this and
then we just collect names and then that
will give us an idea of what's going to
happen on take the session